foreign
[Music]
what's up I know why you asked me here
you got the whole Justice League on your
big office space type of valuations
you're here to fire me I know go ahead
and do it
Vic
cyborg I would never fire you in fact
you're the most useful member of this
team really yeah the lasers the plasma
cannon you fly you're a cowboy you talk
to computers that's the one that blows
me away the most in fact I'd love to see
it in action you know not many people
have to see what I can do I'd love to
help right because yeah my wireless
printer
your printer I tried to connect you to
the back computer and they still can't
talk to each other and yes they're on
the same wireless network my personal
Wi-Fi Gotham and cheese 21. what do you
want me to do about this
I'd like some tech support oh man I'm
hyper Advanced man computer that can
interface with All Electronics not your
personal Geek Squad everybody said Geek
Squad
you're not a squad you're just
one geek guy not your geek guy okay
forget about my printer it is so cold in
here
what do you want it's in that thermostat
man I thought it would help if you could
tell it to make it roasty toasty when
you set a schedule for it because it
will work on its own you just got to set
the schedule yourself okay so you can do
this this is what I'm talking about oh
man you can do this you can do this you
can do this I can't it's easy I can't
I'm not doing it okay then can you help
me get a CD onto my iPhone no I cannot
help you get a CD onto your iPhone I'm
not your gen Z nephew here to teach you
about Tick Tock I'm a human being are
you sure I mean a lot of us think your
ding dong just might be three or four D
batteries
who said that Alfred
well no I said it to Alfred wouldn't it
be great if Cyborg's ding dong was three
or four D batteries and he said very
good sir you just fire me already fire
you
should I bees honestly I would never
fire you all foolishness aside I have a
matter of life and death that only you
can help me with really really this is a
great great matter
okay tell me about it okay
I had some documents photographs and I
deleted those documents and I need to
retrieve them they're highly sensitive
and you need me to access the Mainframe
and get them for you I know there's got
to be a way oh there's definitely way
yes I can do this really yeah just tell
me what the pictures are okay well I
don't know if you ever met my now dead
girlfriend Rachel Dodge she's lovely
sorry for your loss I appreciate that
before she passed in a barrel fire
she had sent me some
delicate photographs
nasty delicious let's just say and I
really enjoyed them but after she died
in a barrel fire I felt sort of wrong
looking at the photos it would have been
very gross yeah without disrespectful so
I deleted him
and
enough time passed
memory faded to Legend and it no longer
feels disrespectful to look at the
photos in fact it feels like a way of
honoring her memory and what do you want
me to do please retrieve the photographs
that I might resume that's debating
and thereby in the Viking tradition
keeper Mary in your life you want me to
help you find your dead girlfriend's
photos
so that you can masturbate you know I'd
look at it and get my ding dong a few
batter eggs
okay how is this a matter of life in
debt stress is a killer you try perching
on a gargoyle for 12 hours looking for
Killer Croc in case he takes surface
streets if you're tense up there no
chance but if you're drained and I mean
drained the way that only a photo of a
naked girlfriend who died in a barrel
fire can drain now you're fighting crime
now you're fighting crime they told me
you were a psychopath and I did not
believe I am not helping you with that
then you're fired you can't fire
me I quit you can't control alt delete
the Justice League hell yes I can I'm
saying I've seen your dating profile too
you're sick before you go
cyborg play smooth jazz
I'm so embarrassed that that worked
cyborg stop cyborg resume
cyborg resume volume ten you fat
man cyborg repeat this song
[Music]
foreign